si le royaume uni la hollande
l'allemagne ont dit un critère de succès
pour venir chez nous c'est d'apprendre
notre langue nationale vous et votre
conjoint conjointe avant de venir
ils savent peut-être quelque chose que
de la lune doit-on parler la langue
nationale avant d'émigrer au royaume uni
aux pays bas ou en allemagne
comme le souligne le chef péquiste et la
réponse est oui mais il ya d'importantes
nuances a souligné par exemple en
allemagne la connaissance préalable de
l'allemand est seulement imposée à ceux
et celles qui veulent rejoindre un
membre de leur famille
l'allemand n'est pas imposée aux
immigrants travailleurs et doivent la
prendre
après cinq ans aux pays-bas certains
immigrants sont exemptes et les migrants
qui l'est du canada des états unis du
japon de l'australie n'a pas besoin de
connaître le néerlandais migrants
exemptes et doit apprendre la langue
seulement s'il veut rester plus de cinq
ans aux pays bas de plus nous avons
parlé à l'auteur de l'étude sur laquelle
se basent jean françois lisée selon lui
exiger une connaissance de la langue
avant d'entrer dans le pays n'est pas un
gage succès et peut même être contre
productif
selon les recherches de cet auteur
l'apprentissage de la langue et les
mesures d'intégration dans la terre
d'accueil produisent le meilleur
résultat